you've been around since the very
beginning
yeah he's the OG he's the OG and the OG
coach Blake Shelton is ready to say
goodbye to the voice after 12 years the
reason you may not even know this the
reason there's four coaches on The Voice
is because it takes three people to go
against me on Tuesday NBC announced the
upcoming 23rd season set to debut in
2023 will be the country crooners final
go round come on buddy what Blake was
trying to tell you is that he's the goat
of the boys in a statement Blake said
he's been wrestling with his decision
for a while and decided it's now time
for him to step away quote this show has
changed my life in every way for the
better and it will always feel like home
to me it's been a hell of a ride over
these 12 years of chair turns when
Carson and I were looking at some of the
pictures that we were seeing last year
because it was the 20th season it's like
oh my God
look how young we are look how skinny I
was back then like what happened to me
when you set your ass in a red chair for
10 years and you don't leave this is
what happens yeah Blake's been all
missing in competition since it debuted
in 2011 and voice fans know he's been
pointing fingers ever since
I gotta go with Blake
Blake says in his statement I've made
lifelong bonds with Carson and every
single one of my fellow coaches over the
years including my wife Gwen Stefani I
can't believe you guys have been
together for seven years so fast what's
the key guys I don't know if there's I
don't know what the secret is we're best
friends ended up being the greatest
moment of my life you know so it's just
it's amazing it truly is the country
star's fellow coach John Legend shared
his well wishes on Twitter writing you
will be missed brother what an
incredible run Blake replied it's been
an absolute blast my friend and it's
true it's been an incredible run for
Blake he's won eight times I love
beating the other coaches it's it's what
they pay me to do actually is and as
viewers know Blake's made it known he's
I've been doing this a long time on this
show too long some might say but with
time the Grammy winners recognized his
priorities have shifted kind of love
music and I love I love the voice I love
all the cool things I get to do with my
job but those things are at all take a
back seat now to to
Gwen and the kids and it's just a new
phase of my life and and uh and because
of that I don't feel like I'm is
necessarily putting myself in in the rat
race anymore now Blake's final season
will be a big one with Kelly Clarkson
the season 21 champ returning and two
new coaches are joining the panel Niall
Horan and Chance the Rapper but it's not
over for Blake yet who's currently a
coach this season and isn't backing down
from a fight did you feel more
competitive or less competitive how
would you categorize it more or less
more more competitive you gotta win for
the household yeah
[Music]